time now for our Bloomberg quick take
where we provide context and background
on issues of interest tropical storms
and hurricanes wreaked havoc around the
globe due to climate change the world's
oceans are warmer plan to say that's
going to mean more storms and more
intense storms here's a situation the
consensus of forecasters is that during
the June November hurricane season the
Atlantic Basin will see more storms than
the 12 that occur in a typical year
hurricane Matthew reached categories 5
strengths before battering Haiti in
October as a category for killing
hundreds and leaving widespread
destruction Matthew was the strongest
storm to strike the region since Felix
back in 2007 meanwhile in August Japan
was hit with its first sigh foon in 11
years here's the background the
devastation caused by hurricanes and
storms has been a constant struggle for
those who live near the sea even before
the new threats posed by climate change
disasters have forced some localities to
rethink their defenses in New Orleans
levees and canals have been used to
harness the Mississippi River for 200
years but a flawed design led to
flooding from Hurricane Katrina in 2005
more than 900 people died and three
quarters of homes in the New Orleans
area were damaged here's the argument
there is a divide brewing on what to do
to prevent the damage or even to rebuild
Tokyo built a massive underground flood
diversion facility and New York is
planning a protection system around
lower Manhattan but some urban planners
and environmentalists are challenging
the right of people to rebuild after
storms